hey what's up guys my name is Shauna
welcome back to this batch rendering
miniseries so last time we took a look
at how we could get textures into our
back definitely check out that video if
you haven't already and today we're
gonna be talking all about dynamic
batching so up until now we've had our
entire batch our vertex buffer kind of
defined up front all the data that's
been in it we've defined at the
beginning of our application and all
we've done every frame is just simply
rendered it we've referenced that
existing data that we've already sent to
the GPU and then just told it to be
rendered we've commanded to be rendered
by redraw call now that's great because
there are heaps of scenarios and games
where we just have like this kind of
static geometry blob and we just want to
keep rendering down we don't really care
about being able to control it but there
are also a lot of cases in which that's
just not gonna cut it we actually need
to be able to frame to frame set the
positions of all these different quads
that we've grouped together into one
draw call into one batch dynamically and
that is what today's video is about but
first I want to thank a Skillshare for
sponsoring in this video so for those of
you who don't know Skillshare is an
online learning community for creatives
where millions come together to take the
next step in their creative journey
Skillshare offers thousands of inspiring
classes for creative and curious people
on topics including illustration design
photography video freelancing and more I
think that pretty much all of you
watching this video right now you're
people who really want to learn more and
that's exactly what Skillshare lets you
do and I love the fact that skill shows
videos are typically so short I mean
mine can go on for quite a while and not
saying that bad but sometimes you just
want to pick up a new skill without
having to watch really long videos and
spend too much of your time actually
learning that because let's be honest I
mean who has tons of time lying around
as people watching these videos on
graphics programming it's really
important that apart from just
programming you have more of a creative
eye and you're aware of like design and
illustration and all of this kind of
creative stuff that ties these graphics
together if you're just kind of boiled
down into that code and that's all you
care about you just in the code
not gonna make anything pretty for
example I really like these creative
illustration classes and in fact this
class is great for helping you to design
a logo make 2020 a year in which you
explore new skills deepen existing
passions and get lost in creativity with
skill shares online classes and with an
annual subscription of less than $10 a
month it's a really good way to actually
do all of that but of course school
shipping lovely company that they are
are offering the first 500 of you to
sign up using the link in the
description below two whole months of
free Skillshare premium so make sure you
jump on that link as soon as possible
and start learning all of those new
skills let me know what kind of skills
you guys end up learning as well there's
so much on that platform I haven't
explored it all yet definitely check it
out and of course as always thank you to
Skillshare for sponsoring this video
okay let's talk about dynamic batch
rendering so there are a few moving
parts when it comes to making your batch
rendering dynamic in fact there's two
kind of main parts and that's the vertex
buffer and the index buffer so today
we're gonna focus specifically on that
vertex buffer as we've seen so far in
this series when our program first
starts up that's when we create this
kind of vertex buffer but what if we
didn't have to predefined all those
vertices right then and there during our
initialization code what if we could
somehow move that responsibility and
make it something that we can actually
do every frame data that we can set
every frame that would mean that we
could dynamically respond true for
example the position of a quad or
something like that or the size of a
quarter
if this quad even has to be rendered or
not it would give us tremendous power
really and the good news of course is
that we can do that and it's actually
pretty simple
all we really have to do is mark our
vertex buffer as dynamic that means that
we can actually set the data inside that
vertex buffer whenever we like we can
just simply copy bytes of memory into
that vertex buffer at some kind of
location there are a few different steps
involved in this but just to quickly
summarize what it is we're gonna do here
when we jump into the code we're
basically going to take the function
that we use to actually set the data and
use it only to allocate an actual buffer
on our GPU that is large enough to hold
all of our vertices we're not going to
set any data at all
and then later on in the actual
rendering code just before we render
we're going to come in and we're going
to copy all that data from our CPU all
of the vertex art that we have there
into OpenGL into our GPU so that we can
then access it and render it as normal
so it's a very simple move when you
think about it we're just literally
taking that block of vertices and moving
them to be in that kind of rendering
function that we're using that gets
called every frame but of course by
doing so we make it dynamic because we
can now calculate that data or respond
to anything really to determine what the
data should be and then upload it then
and there without having to worry about
any kind of predefined data whatsoever
anyway it's gonna be a lot easier to
actually understand when you see the
code and when I walk you through it so
let's dive in and take a look so this is
all the code from last time and if I
launch this we got this result we just
kind of had these two quads being
rendered here with separate textures or
batch together into one draw call and
now what I want to do is take you guys
through what it takes to make this all
dynamic so as I mentioned it's currently
static in the sense that everything that
we defined for this particular batch for
this vertex buffer it's all done like in
this on attach function it's all kind of
set in Storen to be a certain value and
that's it when we come over here into on
update all we're doing here is
essentially binding the textures then
binding the vertex array and just
issuing that draw as well now there are
some things we can still customize like
for example these uniforms here we can
change the camera we can change the
transform of the entire batch and we can
also bind any two textures we want so
the fact that those two are currently
the churner logo and the hazel logo
there's nothing to stop us from flipping
them or introducing another texture we
can do all of that that's all fine but
what we can't do is change the position
of one of the quads for example or
change the size of it or do anything
like that whatsoever because this vertex
data is in fact already inside the
vertex buffer and that vertex buffer is
essentially set in stone so what we're
gonna do is just change all of that
completely so that every frame we
actually create this vertex buffer data
and there are a few ways to actually
achieve something like this so I'm just
gonna show you one of the ways
the ways that I like doing it but just
keep that in mind the idea here and the
thing to really take home here is that
you can dynamically change the contents
of your vertex buffer and that is how
you achieve this dynamic kind of
rendering okay cool let's begin so the
first thing that I'm really gonna do is
not worry about these vertices I mean
they're set up pretty well here but I'm
just going to pretend that they don't
exist
I'm gonna just comment them out the
reason being that even though we could
start with these vertices we're probably
going to want to dynamically set them
every frame so this data will eventually
move into the on update function what
I'll do is I'll come down here into GL
buffer data this is the important kind
of function that we call here because
what this does is well it actually does
a few things apart from just simply
setting these vertices and actually
sending them to our GPU and storing them
in GPU memory it also actually allocates
the buffer on our GPU that will hold all
this data and this is really important
to note because what we can actually do
is basically change how we use this
function completely instead of actually
using it to set data we can just use it
as an allocation function and the way
that we do that is instead of supplying
it with a pointer to a buffer which is
what we're doing here we're giving it
that that vertices pointer which is a
float array which is a float pointer
instead of doing that we can simply give
it null pointer which means when I was
applying it with any data so then the
usefulness of this function falls into
this parameter which is how much data do
we want to allocate in bytes and this is
how we're going to use this function
what we're going to do is we're gonna
just allocate a maximum size for our
vertex buffer and then every frame we're
gonna kind of populate that vertex
buffer with certain data and keep track
of how much data we've actually
populated it with so what we need to do
now is decide how many vertices
essentially we can store inside our
vertex buffer of course arbitrarily
typing in a number like 1024 meaning a
kilobyte of memory that's not really
that useful because obviously this is a
vertex buffer and we want to kind of the
units that we want to use for this are
vertices because we can't have half a
vertex that's useless so what we want to
do is figure out just how big one vertex
is now at the moment everything is just
a bunch of floods which is kind of
annoying it's not really a really nice
way of doing things at all because just
by looking at this it's actually really
hard to tell just by reading it that
these three are the position these four
other color these two are the text
recorder and this is the texture ID that
cutter makes no sense so what we would
probably want to do instead is create a
struct called vertex and inside this
struct we're going to basically have the
structure of each vertex so what we'll
do is we'll have three floats for the
position which I'll write like this then
we'll have four floats for the color
then we'll have the two texture
coordinates so I'll call this text
chords two and finally we'll have a tax
ID as well okay so now we have a
complete vertex that basically replaces
all of this and we can actually set
these up much easier now if we want to
create a new vertex we can do something
like this and then set for example the
position equal to whatever the position
should be without actually having to
just basically have this huge row of
floats which could be interpreted anyway
okay cool so now that we've got that
let's decide how many vertices we want
well just for this example let's just
say we want 1,000 vertices so what we'll
need to do is say size of vertex times
1000 so we've basically created a vertex
buffer that is capable of storing 1000
of these vertices that is how much
memory we've allocated we don't have to
store exactly 1000 or anything like that
that's just the size that's the that's
the entire capacity of a vertex buffer
we can't exceed that but we can
definitely say that you know in this
case for example we only need eight
vertices so we can absolutely just store
eight in there if we want and now
finally this parameter is really
important at the moment it's set to
static draw what this is is a little bit
of a hint to OpenGL to how we're going
to actually use this memory so static
draw means that we've kind of defined
everything statically up front and that
we want to use it for drawing so really
what this is saying is it's going to act
as read-only memory
we're not exactly going to write to it
however we want to write to it every
frame so what we need to do is change
this to read GL dynamic draw so what
this means is that we're going to
dynamically be populating the vertex
buffer and of course
still gonna be using it for drawing if
you're still unsure as to what this
actually means then definitely consult
the OpenGL documentation which will
define it more formally ok cool down
here this remains exactly the same
except instead of having this ten times
float here which is what basically one
vertex is it's ten floats we can simply
write size of vertex which is just going
to kind of clear it up so I'll kind of
just apply that to all of these and
finally another kind of code clarity
thing you can do here is just use the
offset of function here well it's
actually a macro that lets you figure
out the byte offset of any member so in
other words we can use this to actually
get the correct offset in bytes of each
one of these struct members which are of
course our vertex attributes so I'll
copy and paste this into all of these
ones so we have color then we have text
chords then we have text ID and I'll
even do this for the first one just in
case we decide to rearrange our struct
because that means that this will always
work because of course if we do
rearrange this then the offset will also
be rearranged here okay cool so this is
looking a little bit more clear now a
little bit easier to read none of this
changes let's take a look at our index
buffer so what changes with our index
buffer well that's kind of the beauty of
this nothing the index buffer really
shouldn't change because what we're
gonna be doing is just setting this data
dynamically but the fact that to draw a
chord we need to draw index zero one two
and then two three zero that's not gonna
change it's just gonna keep going in
this pattern for as many quads as we
decide to draw so in other words what we
would probably want to do is since we've
marked this as one thousand vertices
which I mean I don't even know how many
quads that is you have to divide it by
four so I guess 250 quads is how many we
can draw with 1030 sees inside our
vertex buffer so 250 quads you would
want enough indices for all of that to
be drawable so typically you'd set up
like a for loop that would basically
continue generating indices ever
ascending in this pattern so we'll take
a look at that in a future video because
I really want to focus on specifically
the vertex buffer here we'll still
pretend that we're drawing two quads
even though technically of course we can
draw a thousand vertices and the next
video will expand the index buffer and
all of that to take care of how to
actually draw any arbitrary amount of
quads which will be quite exciting
so with that
being said if we recap what we've done
basically what we've done apart from
kind of set up a struct here to define
how vertex we've allocated enough memory
for 1,000 vertices but the actual vertex
buffer is still completely empty but
it's been marked as dynamic draw meaning
that we can actually populate it with in
our update loop every frame if we need
to so let's do exactly that I'm going to
come over here and I'm just gonna make
some space because this is where we're
going to actually set our dynamic vertex
buffer so what I want to do is bind the
buffer the same way that I do it here
and then there are a few different ways
to actually do this but essentially what
I want to do is somehow send some data
into that vertex buffer so one of the
ways you can do this is by using GL map
buffer what this will do if we actually
take a look at it here is the actual
function what this will actually do is
return a void pointer to us of memory
that we can actually directly write into
and when we do that and called GL on map
buffer which is kind of the other side
of this function it will actually upload
that buffer to the GPU so that's one way
of doing it in a lot of cases though
this actually ends up being slightly
slower than the method that I'm going to
use and also the method I'm going to use
has the added advantage of the fact that
it's supported in lower versions of
OpenGL and that is gel buffer sub data
so this is extremely similar to GL
buffer data which is what we used here
to actually allocate that memory but
what it does is basically instead of
doing any kind of allocation it just
simply sends that data into that buffer
so what we'll do is type GL array buffer
as that first argument because that's
our target
then we'll have to specify the offset of
this data so since we want to actually
copy this data into the beginning of the
buffer we'll just write 0 here because
there is no offset and then we simply
need the size of the data we're copying
and then a pointer to the actual data so
let's come back over here and we'll
steal our vertices and that's what we'll
do we'll just set these into our buffer
I'll just paste them over here and then
what I'll do is I'll just leave them
intact for now we'll we'll transition
them over to that vertex structure in a
minute but I can still leave them as
float vertices that memories identical
so we'll just say size of vertices and
then finally vertices okay cool so what
we've done here is effectively
dynamically every frame we're now pop
awaiting our vertex buffer with this
vertex data and that's it I mean you
could unbind your buffer but that's not
strictly necessary in this case this is
how we do it keep in mind that we're
still actually only rendering twelve
indices what we've done here is we've
set up our vertex buffer dynamically but
if we come up over here into indices we
are still drawing 12 of these meaning
that well 12 is all we have in this case
but we're just going to be drawing index
0 1 2 2 3 0 for the first quarter then 4
5 6 6 7 4 for that second quad so no
matter what if I duplicate this data if
I do whatever I want with it if I add
more stuff it doesn't matter because
these first 0 to 7 vertices by index
that's actually what's gonna get
rendered because our index buffer
controls what we render from within this
vertex buffer and this controls how many
we actually render ok so if I hit f5 to
run my program here we should get
exactly the same result and you can see
we do ok so what's actually changed well
this is done every frame now which means
we can control these values and in fact
let's go ahead and transition them over
to use our vertex struct I'll pull this
struct out and I'll just put it at the
top of our file here so that the entire
file can actually access this I'll come
over here and I'll make some kind of
function that returns 4 vertices for us
which is what we need to actually render
a quad this is just gonna be a really
simple example to show how we can
actually control this dynamically so
I'll return a standard array of type
vertex and of course we'll have 4 of
these I'll call this create quad and
I'll actually mark it as static and then
let's take in X and y as arguments
meaning we can actually control the
position of this quad then what I'll do
is simply create the vertices so I'll
have my vertex V 0 which is going to be
my first vertex I'm gonna set the
position of that equal to let's go ahead
and just copy this stuff to begin with
because this will take a little bit of
time and in fact what I'm gonna do is
just fast-forward through this as I copy
all of this data and just simply put
them into the relevant vertex ok cool so
that looks pretty good to me and then
finally I can just return v-0 v1 v2 and
v3 as our array okay so now we have a
really simple way of just getting four
vertices
and then customizing them based on these
parameters so let's actually make that
happen we'll kind of set the size of
these to be one meaning a quarter be a 1
by 1 unit quad and then just for
simplicity sake we'll assume that the
bottom left corner is actually kind of
the origin of this squad meaning this
will simply set to be X&Y and now this
will be X plus size and just Y this will
also be X plus size and then now we'll
have y plus size and then over here
we'll just have x and y plus size okay
cool so now we have all of our vertex
positions set up the color we've
currently hot carded to be this value
but it doesn't really matter we're using
textures now so the other thing that
I'll do is just simply take in a texture
ID here and this texture ID is what
we'll actually put into this attribute
over here so we have a texture ID for
all of our vertices ok cool there we go
we should now be able to use this to
draw quads so what I'll do I'll call my
create quad function and then I'll pass
in negative one point five and negative
zero point five which is what this used
to be of course and then a texture ID of
zero so that's great that's my first
quad and then my second quad is going to
be at 0.5 negative 0.5 so I'll keep the
negative 0.5 here and we'll just change
this to be 0.5 cool so I've got my two
quads now but obviously I need to
actually add them to some kind of buffer
of memory that I can then give to this
GL buffer sub data function so what I'll
do is keep this real simple I'll just
say order Q 0 for quad zero order Q 1
for quad 1 and then I'll allocate enough
storage for both of these quads so in
other words I know that two quads are
going to be 8 vertices so we'll save
vertex vertices 8 and then I'll simply
mem copy all of that data here so I'll
say in two vertices I'm going to copy
all of Q zero dot data and that's going
to be Q zero dot size times size of the
vertex and then I'm going to do the same
thing for Q one except this is now going
to be vertices plus 4 or vertices plus Q
zero size if you really don't want to
heart cut anything and now that we've
got this I'm just going to hide all of
this data by just commenting it out and
obviously we've called it the same thing
so vertices should in fact be
here let's run our program and see what
we get and of course I seem to have
forgotten that arrays like is a non
assignable so what we'll do is just go
to our vertex and simply make a struct
called vector 3 which will be just a
three component vector here and then
I'll do the same for vector and vector
four rearrange these and then we'll
simply change this to be a vector e
we'll change this to be a vector for
this will be a vector two and then we
have a float obviously in a real example
you probably use a math library so you
wouldn't be doing any array stuff anyway
okay cool so now hopefully our code will
compile and now that it does let's take
a look at what we get ok cool so we
looks like we have the same result but
they have the same texture and I guess
that would be because we passed the same
texture index so we'll pass a texture
index of one into our second quad and
now we should get the exact same result
as before and you can see here it is
pretty cool stuff but here is where it
gets cooler and we can really take
advantage of this dynamic stuff what I'm
gonna do is out of control - I'm gooey
I'll just write I am gooey begin
controls and then we'll simply make an
I'm going control for the actual
position of our quad so we'll say drag
float to odd position we'll pass in a
member variable called quad position
which we haven't made yet and then we'll
just write the speed as 0.1 so what I'll
do is I'll go over here into our header
file I'll write float and quad position
and we can set it equal to negative one
point five negative zero point five
which is what it was in the first place
and then what I'll do is I'll actually
use this as the position for our first
quad here and now if I hit f5 you can
see I have these controls here for this
quad and if I move this you can see the
quad actually moves and of course this
one doesn't because we're just
dynamically setting the vertices inside
our vertex buffer so now we can
dynamically render our batch and that's
all there is to it our vertex buffer is
now completely dynamic now there is the
other part of this and that is what
about the index buffer how do we set
that up now that in itself is not all
that hard I want you guys as an exercise
to go ahead and try that out right now
just try and make that index buffer
handle more than just two quads maybe
render three quarts or one quad or
ten quads or something like that you
should just be able to extend that index
buffer and then change the amount of
indices that you actually render inside
your geo draw elements function and that
that's all there is to it early so what
we're going to do in the next video is
talk about that specifically and I'm
just going to kind of add some more UI
to control all these things so that we
can maybe add and remove quads and do
something like that and have a pretty
solid batch rendering example that is
completely dynamic many way I hope you
guys enjoyed this video if you did
please hit that like button leave a
comment with your thoughts or if
anything was unclear and I'll try and
get back to you and help you out don't
forget to check out Skillshare link in
description below first 500 people get
two months of free Skillshare premium
and I will see you guys next time
goodbye
[Music]